the trumps top allies British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson announced this
morning that he has tested positive for
the corona virus he's now in
self-isolation at his London residence
that's 10 Downing Street and he's still
running the British government Johnson
last met Queen Elizabeth on March 11th
Buckingham Palace says she remains in
good health our Elizabeth Palmer is in
London for us Elizabeth good morning
how's the Prime Minister doing well
we've been seeing a lot of him he's been
giving a press conference at the end of
every day with his senior officials to
bring the nation up to date on the
crisis but today he suddenly popped up
earlier than normal all alone on Twitter
I've developed mild symptoms of the
corona virus that's to say a temperature
and a persistent cough and on the advice
of the chief medical officer I've taken
a test that has come out positive
yesterday evening there were no signs
the Prime Minister was ill when he came
out of Downing Street to lead a round of
applause for Britain's health workers he
had come under fire at the start of this
outbreak for slow walking restrictions
on movement and Britain's continued to
socialize in pubs and restaurants long
after other European countries had shut
down but he did finally pose a
near-total lockdown earlier this week
and now we learned that Britain has
almost 12,000 cases of corona virus I
should say that's still a fraction of
those in Italy France and Germany but
the number here is still climbing fast
Johnson said in his video but even in
isolation thanks to what he called the
wizardry of modern technology he would
still be leading the national fight back
against coronavirus now he's the second
public figure here to get coronavirus
Prince Charles came down with it that
was announced on Wednesday Gayle
hey Liz do we know of Prince Charles and
Boris Johnson had any contact I noticed
you said that he was at the palace on
March 11th well the the vector for
Prince Charles had been pointing toward
a European royal gathering
now we don't know whether that he then
came across here in effect other people
certainly that's not even part of the
scuttlebutt yet but watch this space we
will be watching this space and watching
you thank you very much Elizabeth Palmer
reporting from London